[Music]  Kylie Jenner steps out for the first  time since giving birth to her first  child here's the first time mom spotted  running errands in LA on Saturday with  her bestie Jordan woods  Kylie kept things casual in a beige  jacket black bicycle shorts and a  matching fanny pack covering her  midsection it's nice to see the reality  star out and about after months of being  reclusive it's been a little over a week  since Kylie and Travis Scott welcomed  their baby girl on February 1st but  Kylie isn't showing off daughter stormy  Webster in public just yet  20 year old Kylie has only given fans a  glimpse of baby store me on Instagram  and shared a special vlog style video of  her pregnancy and birth of the newborn  titled - our daughter  so I'm 34 weeks today if Kylie's  pregnancy is any indication it might be  a while before stormy makes her big  debut in the spotlight  [Music]  you